right the Inspector General Michael
Horowitz has a lot of explaining to do
after 18 months of work his report was
released last Thursday and it shows the
huge massive missteps corruption
mistakes surrounding the FBI in the
Department of Justice during the
so-called Clinton investigation
including example after example how the
fix was in from the get-go to help
Hillary Clinton and literally destroy
then candidate Donald Trump
however the IG did not make
prosecutorial conclusions about the
obvious felonies that Hillary committed
and was totally and unjustly exonerated
from now the facts are actually as we
have been telling you from the get-go
and they are irrefutable mishandling
classified top secret information on a
private server obstructing justice
deleting 33,000 subpoenaed emails acid
washing the harddrive with bleach pit
and having aides destroy evidence
devices with a hammer
oh and removing SIM cards any other
American all of you out there would have
been locked up thrown in prison for
exactly what Hillary Clinton did now
still the IG report did not fault the
FBI's decision to clear Clinton of all
charges what they really decided is
quote not to second-guess the
conclusions while they in fact presented
what is now a mountain of evidence
proving the guilt and sadly the swamp
protects the swamp it is now clear if
Hillary Rodham Clinton had a real
investigation
she would have been indicted now
politics at the highest level of the FBI
sadly prevented all of that let's for
example break things down in these
findings down and see if any reasonable
person would ever make the conclusion
that political bias did not play a major
role inside the FBI let's look at this
text August 8th 2016 high-ranking FBI
attorney Lisa page and her colleague
boyfriend Peter struck who was the lead
investigator in the Clinton case and
Lisa page
she writes Trump's not ever going to
become president right struc responds
quote no no he's not we will stop it and
then Lisa page called Trump an enormous
well expletive add to that the list of
insults both page and struck lobbed
against Donald Trump he's an idiot he's
a menace he's alone some human being and
so much more
remember all of this is from the lead
investigator and the lead FBI attorney
but the bias didn't stop with them look
at this message from yet another high
ranking agent on this case Trump
supporters are all poor to middle class
uneducated lazy POS is that think that
he will magically grant them jobs for
doing nothing and for months before the
election one agent who actually
interviewed Hillary Clinton called her
the president in a message to a
colleague and said quote Trump can't win
and then on October 28 2016 shortly
after Comey announced that he would be
reopening the Clinton investigation
while another unnamed FBI attorney sent
an instant message to a fellow FBI
employee and that read I'm clinging to
small pockets of happiness in the dark
times of they were publics destruction
I'm following Trump's election victory
that same FBI attorney sent an instant
message in that read quote I am numb
with a fellow employee responding I
can't stop crying and get this according
to the IG report quote agents involved
in the Clinton Foundation investigation
were instructed to take no overt
investigative steps prior to the
election would you get that treatment
now this of course as the report found
that the FBI was actually intimidated by
Clinton's high ranking legal team and
the report also found that high-ranking
DOJ officials tried to get a job for his
son in the Clinton campaign all while
sharing leaking case information about
the ongoing server investigation -
Clinton campaign chairman John Podesta
it's unbelievable and by the way believe
it or not there's so much more listen to
what Senator Lindsey Graham layed out at
today's hearing he was on fire take a
look now this was an email sent in
February 2016 from page two McCabe hey
you've surely already considered this
but in my view our best
reason to hold the line at two and two
to agents and to prosecutors is she
might be our next president how did you
feel about that we were concerned about
it and we lay it at layout here why we
were okay let's keep talking about this
interview one of the FBI agents in the
interview said on Election Day to
another FBI agent you should know that
I'm with her now her was Clinton right
correct how do you feel about that very
concerned okay
eventually very concerned gives to be
enough already I'm glad you found what
you found miss Rhodes I'm not buying
that the Clinton email investigation was
on the up-and-up I'm not buying it
either still think political bias didn't
play a role in the FBI's decisions now
don't forget at the center of all of
this is FBI Trump aiding agent Peter
struck now he's now being subpoenaed by
the House Judiciary Committee in order
to better determine why the FBI and the
DOJ withheld many of his antitrump texts
we still haven't gotten them all
remember he was the lead FBI agent in
the Hillary Clinton investigation he's
the one that vowed to stop a trump
presidency in a text with his girlfriend
Lisa Paige and according to the IG
report Paige was a high-ranking FBI
attorney who was used by Andrew McCabe
yeah that Andrew McCabe of course to
bypass the FBI's chain of command and he
got to monitor the Clinton investigation
we have long reported about McCabe's
Democratic bias next we knew that Peter
struck Andrew wiesmann GT R a those
names sound familiar and so many of all
these anti Trump Democratic donors all
tapped the same people to finish the
exoneration of Hillary and put the fix
in and then tapped by robert muller for
his trump russia witch-hunt now in fact
many of those same agents that cleared
hillary they were then immediately
appointed to investigate Trump now the
very agents just spewing hatred about
Trump now e to stop his presidency
mocking Trump supporters the same people
tapped to investigate Trump a move even
questioned
by the inspector-general which means
that the entire Russia investigation
from the get-go was as corrupt as the
Hillary coverup and it was the case from
day one and there's a very definition
itself right there of what I've been
saying a two-tier justice system no
equal justice under the law or equal
application of our laws now if true
justice had prevailed if Hillary Clinton
got indicted as she should have in the
fall of 2016 the electoral process would
have been turned on its head the deep
States choice for president would be out
of the race Trump would actually be the
president without any of this Muller
garbage that he's had to deal with
almost his entire presidency and that's
why Hillary Clinton she got the White
Glove treatment by these investigators
openly rooting for her to win the
election President Trump everyone
associated with him they got the
sledgehammer thrown down by the very
same people that gave Hillary a pass and
tonight we're also learning James Comey
is under investigation for mishandling
classified information
remember he intentionally leaked his
personal notes about conversations he
had with the president that's illegal
you're not allowed to do that in order
to set the ball rolling for the
anti-trump special counsel his buddy
Robert Muller to begin his investigation
or which on and the IG also found as FBI
director Comey was insubordinate and
totally mishandled the Clinton
investigation now legal scholar Jonathan
Turley a Democrat he's now saying these
findings in the IG report exonerate
Trump from any obstruction of justice
charges which means as you all end and
then now take a look to me the
obstruction claim involving Comey was
always difficult but after the IG it's
become virtually incomprehensible
because the IG said that Comey was
insubordinate that he deviated from
policies he violated FBI policies all
those are a good reason to fire James
Comey and so the problem is that's going
to come up for the critics of President
Trump is that this dog just won't hunt
when you've got both the IG and the
Deputy Attorney General
saying he deserved to be fired you can't
assume everything against him there's
another interesting aspect here if
column if molar was really going after
obstruction based on Comey then
Rosenstein would have to recuse himself
Rosenstein said that if Muller told him
that he was a witness he would remove
himself he hasn't done that which makes
me think
one of two things either Miller's
ignoring conflicts of interest or he's
not seriously pursuing that angle now
meanwhile president Trump's attorney
Rudy Giuliani is calling for an
investigation into the investigators
something we have been discussing for a
long time take a look it was one of five
individuals outlined in this IG report
as potentially facing disciplinary
action are you calling for something
sharper than that yeah you done right
disciplinary action went when he's
making comments like that not part of
the probe he started it he was with it
for it's for its for its first couple of
months Muller kept him on so how much
did he infect that probe with his own
very very extreme positions I don't know
but I sure want to find out before I go
forward I mean this is a case where it's
crying out for someone to investigate
the investigators absolutely and even
deep state sycophant turned CNN fake
news pundits improper he's now ready for
mobile to wrap all this up frankly he
likely knows that he and Brennan will
eventually be exposed take a look I
think the overarching point here is this
whole issue has got to come to
resolution at some point especially
counsel Muller and his team I hope will
wrap up the investigation clear the year
one way the other whether or not there
was a collusion with the Russians this
is a cloud that's hanging over the
country and certainly hanging over this
presidency and I do hope that happens
well change our heart now we're gonna
have a lot more on Muller and the IG
report in just a moment first let's turn
to a story that is causing a five-alarm
fire in the halls of the mainstream
destroy Trump media surrounding reports
that the children of illegal immigrants
are being separated from their
upon entering the country illegally look
let's start and be very clear nobody
nobody wants children who are safely in
the custody of their parents separated
nobody wants that but truth matters and
facts matter earlier today DHS secretary
Kristen Nielsen responded to these
claims she set the record straight with
important information that the media is
all too happy as usual to ignore take a
look so let's just start with a few
numbers and facts so in the last three
months we have seen illegal immigration
on our southern border exceed 50,000
people each month multiples over each
month last year since this time last
year there has been a 325 percent
increase in unaccompanied alien children
and a 435 percent increase in family
units entering the country illegally
over the last 10 years there has been a
1,700 percent increase in asylum claims
resulting in asylum backlog today on our
country of 600,000 cases since 2013 the
United States has admitted more than
half a million illegal immigrant miners
and family units from Central America
most of whom today are at large in the
United States at the same time large
criminal organizations such as ms-13
have violated violated our borders and
gained a deadly foothold within the
United States this entire crisis just to
be clear is not new it's been occurring
and expanded over many decades but
currently it is the exclusive product of
loopholes and our federal immigration
laws that prevent illegal immigrant
miners and family members from being
detained and removed to their home
countries then secretary Neilson went on
to explain wise in some rare cases the
children of the illegal immigrants are
separated from their parents here's what
she said DHS does have a responsibility
to protect minors and in that case as
well we will only separate the family if
we cannot determine there is a familiar
relationship if the child may be at risk
with the parent or legal guardian or if
the parent or legal guardian is referred
for prosecution
and Nielsen also made an important
comparison to how the government treats
our own citizens Oh important take a
watch let's be clear if an American were
to commit a crime anywhere in the United
States they would go to jail and they
would be separated from their family
this is not a controversial idea and
finally secretary nielsen reminded
everyone in the media that this is
nothing new and took place in previous
administrations
yeah facts matter take a look the last
administration the Obama administration
the Bush administration all separated
families at them and they absolutely did
well they did their rate was less than
ours but they absolutely did do this
this is not new miners there's no doubt
about that but this they separated
families a very important point remember
the photo showing immigrant children in
cages some of the media first attributed
that picture to the Trump administration
and it would actually occurred of course
during the Obama administration in fact
the Obama administration not the Trump
administration they're the ones that
started a policy of actually detaining
miners younger than 18 for months but
the media of course didn't report barely
yond in fact one Democrat actually did
admit that Obama was able to somehow
keep his actions at the border very
quiet wonder why so under the Obama
administration there was according to
the Washington Post reporting you know a
surging number of unaccompanied minors
being apprehended at the border in 2014
there were nearly 70,000 according to
the Post reporting in many ways that I
think I was I don't know what image
you're using but I released some of
those photos because it was kept very
quiet under the Obama administration
there were large numbers of people
coming in the Obama administration was
trying to keep this quiet
of course no outrage from the media over
Obama but with Trump it's a totally
different story and of course there's
another factor here they want a
distraction from all the lies they have
been peddling to you for the last 18
months and as I said earlier no one
likes the idea of separating any child
from any parent but this issue has been
in the hands of Congress and right now
the whole issue can be fixed every law
can be changed and if they did their job
it would
happen it is the law Democrats of course
prefer to make it a political issue they
want to win in 2018 they want their
power back those on the left only want
open borders which means this issue
probably is not going away they need to
come to the table agree to a serious
immigration reform including the
construction of the wall they already
had the president concede on daca but
they prefer to demagogue rather than fix
the issue
sad reality